[Music]
[Applause]
Matt Miller works for the mothership
covering the draft he writes for
espn.com contributes to a variety of
shows including NFL live and get up uh
thanks for joining us Matt at what point
did you realize it was time to tear up
your mock draft last night
uh two overall so about 7 30 central
time was when I was ready to go that's
you know I know I'm not the only one but
we've said all throughout this draft
process it's the most unpredictable year
I've been doing this since 2011. it's
the most unpredictable year I've ever
covered because we didn't know what
Houston was going to do and it's so
funny you heard from camps throughout
the last week they love will Anderson
and I'd reported this they had a grade
on Will Anderson that was like perfect
on your draft board it's like a 9.0 or
whatever scale they use but then I even
had someone grab me in the lobby the
other night they're going CJ Stroud
they're going CJ Stroud like okay I'm
hearing about these things they're all
right they were both right they did Love
Will Anderson and they did grab CJ
Stroud so at a huge cost obviously they
paid a lot to do that but uh Houston
definitely set the mock draft world on
fire okay why did Houston disguise this
so much for so long that they wanted CJ
Stroud
I don't there's no reason there really
isn't when you were on the clock and I
think we've known for about a month that
it was good three weeks that it was
going to be Bryce young so the only
thing I can come up with Dan is maybe
there was some legitimate you know
conversation up into the point of the
draft starting and usually what happens
you know the morning of the draft you're
finally presenting the plan to the owner
saying hey here's what we're gonna do
and things can change at that point uh
so maybe Cal McNair said wait I want
both these guys what's that gonna take
but I I do know the Texans have been
laying the groundwork to move up in the
days before the draft so maybe they're
also like maybe they're smoking out
leaks in this you know they they let
Jack easterby go he was kind of known as
a talker a little bit so maybe they're
saying hey we got a new front office or
news coaching structure a new
organizational structure let's find out
who's leaking so we're gonna put this
out and we're gonna put that out and
we're gonna see where it's coming from I
like what Arizona did I don't like the
team but I like what they did and they
and they got the the person that the
player they wanted in Paris John and
then you had the Colts they were staying
there they weren't moving up it felt
like they weren't flinching that they
were locked in on now was it whoever was
going to be available or was it going to
be we're taking Anthony Richardson
I think the Colts were set on we will
take whoever's available we'll take one
of the guys whether it was going to be
Richardson or Stroud let me take
whoever's available hey I'm with you I
like what Arizona did trading down Paris
Johnson is going to look great blocking
for Caleb Williams next year because I
just don't know that we're ever gonna
see Kyle is Kyler the guy there okay
Tyler's the guy they paid him all this
money
oh Carson Wentz got paid chair Goff got
paid I don't know that that matters
anymore if you're not the guy you're not
the guy you've got a new head coach a
new GM we'll see you know I'm rooting
for Kyler but I I the second that trade
was announced the first thing I thought
was they're gonna have a lot of picks if
they want to go get Caleb Williams next
year a lot of picks and so you had to
start you got to start thinking ahead
who's who's going to be the team that
that has eyes for next year's you know
unbeatable generational prospects all
right you're first on the board with
that uh possibility there for Arizona
and and I was mentioning this I wouldn't
have gone crazy for a quarterback this
year if I got one great yeah but I know
next year's class is always better than
this year's class at least in our mind
but it feels like there's three
quarterbacks next year who are who are
better than these quarterbacks or would
be rated higher so you're gonna have
Drake yeah Caleb and panics at
Washington would probably they might
fall grade out higher than these guys
yeah and there's always the unknown
there's always the guy that comes from
nowhere as well you know maybe Quinn
figures it out of Texas and becomes the
guy uh I'm I'm holding my breath on that
we'll see if it happens but you're right
I think with Caleb coming out of USC
there are fewer questions about him same
with Drake May right now after a year of
watching them play Caleb for a year and
a half there are fewer questions now
their holes might get poked in them over
the next 12 months that that certainly
happens but I can tell you like talking
to Scouts general managers even agents
over the past couple months a lot there
are a lot of conversations already about
next year and I always think it's
interesting when a team sets themselves
up for the future Philadelphia has done
that yeah better than anyone they do a
great job of let's keep an eye on the
future we want to always have two
first-round picks if we can and now now
Arizona's that team that is really set
up for next year if they want to be the
pick that bothered you the most last
night
um I I feel badly saying this because
he's a good player but Jamir gives it 12
overall was a shock to me I I had him as
like an early second round pick he's you
know under 200 pounds he's a smaller guy
he's a lot like what they have in
DeAndre Swift he's a slasher back who
catches the ball he is a great receiver
out of the backfield he's a dangerous
kick returner maybe if you put the label
on on him as an offensive weapon they're
going to lose Jamison Williams to a
suspension but why not trade down matt
exactly that's my problem Dan and they
so they did it again with Jack Campbell
they took two good players at bad values
yes you're right running back and
linebacker are the two most d-valued
positions in the NFL draft and Gibbs is
not Bijan Robinson let's just be upfront
about that where you think Beach on a
eight like okay this dude we've only
seen a couple players like this before
Gibbs is like it would be like drafting
Jamal Charles that's his ceiling best
case scenario Jamal Charles probably
gonna have a short career but be a
really good player in that span because
of his burst but you could have traded
it down you didn't have to worry about
the green Green Bay Packers selecting
him at 13. you didn't have to worry
about New England selecting him at 14.
especially with the way the board was
falling with good corners on the board
still good wide receivers the way it was
playing out Detroit could have traded
twice in the first round it's still got
these guys
he's Matt Miller the ESPN NFL draft
analyst he writes for espn.com if you
were going to look at who missed out
more on the player they really wanted
the Jets or the Cowboys
oh the Jets and this was so predictable
the minute they traded from 13 to 15 and
everything you heard was they didn't
want to do it that was the last nail in
the coffin they don't want to do it I
love I love the chaos of the draft so
when when you see the way the board's
falling and here come the Pittsburgh
Steelers with a gigantic need at left
tackle and the New York Jets were the
gigantic need it left tackle Pittsburgh
jumps one spot ahead it takes the last
tackle on the last tackle with the first
round great and Broderick Jones so I
think the Jets
I think they may have panicked a little
bit will McDonald is a fine player I
don't particularly think he should have
been drafted at 15 at 240 pounds uh and
especially when you drafted Jermaine
Johnson last year in the first maybe
he'll be the new Carl Lawson there and
and people can replay this and I'll be
wrong but it felt like the Jets got
jumped and then didn't necessarily have
a plan right there I don't know if
Dallas got who they wanted though Matt
I don't know I think they wanted donkey
yeah yeah I mean I think they want a dog
Cade uh the the room didn't look great
when it popped up on TV you know they
didn't look like they were super happy
Smith's a good player and if he's gonna
you know give Micah Parsons more clean
looks off the edge that's great if he
can stop the run in that division which
you're gonna have to be able to stop the
run in the East with all the weapons
that are there but yeah that one felt
like a team that probably wanted to be
able to trade back after they got jumped
and just didn't have time to do it could
everybody everybody be wrong about will
Levis
so I how do you mean that I had will
Levis rated 25th on my board Dan I
thought he was more of a second round
pick than a first round pick okay so if
I don't know which side I would say I
was on the side of he should not have
been drafted in the top five okay
melker's shouting last night take take
him at number two
I love Mel uh that's the beauty of
evaluation is we can watch the same
player we could sit down together in the
same room watch the same player and have
different opinions and I think for Levis
it's 2021 you saw the promise the upside
2022. I saw a guy who couldn't get the
ball out there were times he was just
tight in the pocket you know he's
clutching onto the ball afraid to make a
mistake so there's kind of that yin and
yang and it doesn't help when you hear
things like hey he's kind of like Carson
Wentz and it's like okay well which
Carson Wentz am I getting and it's like
yeah that's that's the point we don't
know which which player you're gonna get
so
um could be wrong this could be the
motivation he needs you know I I always
felt like he was a like a type a
perfectionist personality anyway to
where I don't know that he needs a
bigger chip on his shoulder you know I
think that already existed and you know
with the way that he's kind of been
overlooked in this project process but
um maybe it'll work the Rams at 36 his
offensive coordinator was with him last
year no team will have better Intel or
will Levis in the LA Rams and they could
use a quarterback of the future if the
Rams
we probably know a little bit more about
why he's falling at this point whether
it be the toe injury the injuries he had
last year the 23 interceptions or
reports that he wasn't interviewing
particularly well what about Hendon
hooker when does he go yeah I think he
goes early as well so I'm a hinden
hooker fan I I said on one of our things
I would take any hooker over will Levis
and I got mocked ruthlessly so we'll see
what happens but I think that we we see
teams Detroit makes a lot of sense if
they want to go QP of the future I still
think Seattle Team Hendon would be
perfect in Seattle because of the deep
ball ability what he does as a runner
really threw five interceptions the last
two years in the SEC while playing in an
offense that pushes the ball down the
field I mean they're not just throwing
check screens and and dumping it off
they're attacking so I think he'll he'll
go fairly early especially with the
report you know this week that he's
gonna be ready to go sooner than
everybody thought good to talk to you
Matt have fun tonight
thanks Dan appreciate you that's Matt
Miller ESPN NFL draft analyst
contributes to multiple shows you see
him on get up NFL live and he writes for
espn.com